chose à payer et qui arrivent pas l'état
les aide comme il peut mais on en a déjà
parlé ici est ce qu'ils gagnaient au
noir il ya les primes etc
ils ont du mal à s'en sortent s'appelait
après vous avez des gens qui sont au
chômage partiel depuis dix mois et au
chômage partiel depuis 10 mois peut-être
que si financièrement ça tient
humainement c'était épouvantable
donc non plus c'est pas des procureurs
eux c'est des gens qui supportent une
situation extraordinairement pénible est
qui et qui la supportent vaillamment
alors ensuite il regarde la façon dont
les choses se font peut-être qu'il ya
des excédents les critiques peut-être
qu'il des foules parfois leur irritation
sur ceux qui nous gouvernent
mais il n'empêche que la dernière crise
politique qui a provoqué la colère des
français
et là même qui a provoqué la colère des
manuels macron c'est à dire les vaccins
donc le premier procureur de
l'administration française et de son
gouvernement ça a été emmanuel macron
qui a dit au journal du dimanche on est
ridicules faut tout reprendre en main
donc je ne comprends pas cette formule
qui consiste à reporter sur
l'intégralité d'un pays
une responsabilité qui incombe à ceux
qui ont décidé de se présenter aux
suffrages pour le gouverner s'il avait
dit 66 millions d'épidémiologistes
commune à 66 millions de sélectionneurs
de l'équipe de france c'était amusant il
a raison tout le monde rock et des
spécialistes qu'aux vide et très peu de
temps le son mais là je pense que ce mot
et je termine comme ça procureur porte
en lui quelque chose du style de négatif
même si les procureurs sont utiles
justice mais enfin dans l'est dans
l'imaginaire collectif c'est pas quand
même on préfère dire je suis l'avocat 2
plutôt que le procureur et puis ça
renvoie aussi à un autre élément qui est
en creux dans toute cette histoire
depuis le début qui le risque pénal
c'est à dire le procureur c'est celui
qui vous poursuit et qui peut vous faire
condamner et vous mettre en prison donc
je pense c'est particulièrement
maladroit et que ça va continuer en tout
cas ça ne va pas apaiser ceux qui
souffrent de cette période et ça va
peut-être développer de chez eux
une forme de rancune ou de petites
colères absolument inutile lucile genre
sur twitter dit je pense surtout que si
macron fait face à 66 millions de
procureur sait qu'il n'a ni réussi à
convaincre ni réussi à enthousiasmer
personnes cette phrase est effectivement
est très maladroite mais à mon avis
emmanuel macron confond le comportement
de son opposition politique parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya un sentiment de
harcèlement assez fort qu'il s'agit de
l'opposition de droite où l'opposition
de gauche c'est à dire qu'effectivement
dès que le gouvernement propose quelque
chose il n'a pas de droit à l'erreur et
moi je je crois que j'ai déjà regretté
sur ce plateau le fait qu' on est une
opposition qui à mon avis n'est pas
assez responsables dans une période
d'incertitude la deuxième chose par
rapport aux français c'est
qu'effectivement il ya une spécificité
de la france par rapport à d'autres pays
européens comme l'allemagne sur le fait
que les sondages montrent que nous avons
un niveau de défiance extrêmement élevé
par rapport au gouvernement mais ça
c'est j'allais dire traditionnelle et ça
a été renforcée par le cos vide mais on
peut pas considérer que être méfiants ou
être défiant de dire qu'on est un
procureur
la troisième chose c'est emmanuel macron
a l'habitude d'avoir ces formules ont
100 je pense chez lui une espèce de goût
du verbe est ce que c'était atral j'en
sais rien mais rappelons nous de la
façon dont il a parlé de l'écologie des
amish rappelons nous comment il avait
dit devant l'elysée un jeune homme qui
lui disait qu'il voulait est
horticulteur et de traverser la rue et
vous trouverez du travail donc il a
l'habitude de ces sorties provocatrice
peut-être sans toujours se poser la
question de quelle est la situation des
gens la vie des gens c'est exactement ce
que vient de dire vincent s qui connaît
la vie des français je crois qu'il a eu
tout à fait tort de généraliser de
parler de 66 millions s'il avait dit
nous avons à faire dans le jeu politique
français à une opposition qui ne nous
laisse pas faire
qui donne des leçons sans savoir qui
n'aimerait pas être à notre place ça je
crois que 66 millions de français
l'aurez compris mais là avec cette
généralité
il se met dans une situation où il est
en train au fond d'amalgamé des
situations puisqu'ils n'ont rien à voir
comme comme l'a dit vincent entre le
fait d'être totalement protégé comme un
certain nombre de professions faire du
télétravail d'être restaurateurs d'être
petit artisan etc
est-ce qu'il a bien compris la diversité
aussi des situations dans lesquelles
nous nous trouvons est ce qu'il comprend
pardon juste termine là dessus est ce
qui comprend la situation des étudiants
de la jeunesse dont on a parlé plus des
étudiants quand il a déclaré je trouve
ça incroyablement il ya une absence
d'empathie que je trouve incroyable
effectivement il était au plateau de
saclay donc ils et elles étaient fondées
sur des théories étudiante la valeur de
la vie en plus c'est ce qui est là où
c'est maladroit c'est que tout son
travail depuis la crise des gilet jaune
a été de réconcilier de france qui ne se
parlaient plus et qui se résumer par une
célèbre formule qui est en eux et nous 1
il ya eu ces pouvoirs et nous c'est ce
qu'on écoute pas c'était ça la
revendication des jeunes
et là on a l'impression qu'ils 10 mois
est un bon président mauvais français
qu'en gros on fait tout ce qu'on peut et
il ya des gens qui ne comprennent pas et
qui nous met en accusation
moi je pense ça m'a fait penser à cette
célèbre phrase de raymond aron qu'on
devrait tous avoir en tête avant de
faire des critiques qui et quand vous
voyez un gouvernant prendre une décision
mettez-vous à sa place et dites vous
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire moi si
j'étais et très vite les critiques que
l'on porte se réduise pas ce qu'on voit
la complexité de la situation mais moi
j'aimerais renverser la proposition de
raymond aron et dire que quand les
hommes politiques prennent une décision
font une déclaration se met-il à la
place de ceux qui vont entendre cette
déclaration ou qui vont subir cette
décision et là on a l'impression que non
parce que à la place de faim il ya quand
même un trouble psychologique profond
dans le pays avec l'atmosphère dans
laquelle on est qu'il laisse entendre
que nous allons reconfigurer peut-être
bientôt
et ça n'est pas du tout le moment de
mettre en accusation
ceux qui vivent dans ce trouble dans
cette défiance ou danser et science est
donc là il ya une une fin comment dire
il ya une wave méconnaissance ou une
ignorance de la psychologie collective
qui est celle de la france aujourd'hui
c'est quand même très étonnant je
reviens pardon lucide sur la question
que pose cet internaute
macron dit que l'un des problèmes c'est
la défiance mes billets pour rien
franchement non mais à l'évidence son
comportement fin les mots qu'il a
prononcés ou les mots la manière dont
ils s'adressent aux pays joue un rôle
moi je reviens sur l'allemagne parce que
la façon dont angela merkel a multiplié
par trois ou quatre sa popularité depuis
le début de la pandémie est
extraordinaire et comment est-ce qu'elle
a choisi alors les allemandes sont pas
les français
mais comment est-ce qu'elle a choisi de
s'adresser aux allemands elle l'a fait
en est une scientifique donc elle l'a
fait avec des mots simples et avec un
langage très concret et parfois avec
émotion alors même que elle est habituée
à garder une forme de distance
donc ça c'est intéressant il faudrait
que emmanuel macron imagine qu'est ce
que c'est que un couvre-feu à 18 heures
d'ailleurs que au fond cette histoire du
eux et nous ou 2e et moi parce que ces
mêmes pavés nous c'est quelque part moi
compte seul contre tous dans 66 millions
de français c'est aussi une
méconnaissance de ce qu'est aujourd'hui
notre vie quotidienne va dire vous allez
au travail ou pas vous ne vous ne savez
pas comment gérer vos enfants vous ne
savez pas comment faire vos courses
donc il ya ce sentiment d'éloignement de
ceux qui ont le pouvoir et de la société
qui s'est renforcée depuis que le
couvre-feu la possibilité de re confinés
comme comme on vient de le dire vient
encore donner le sentiment que là pour
le coup il ya un truc de stop and go et
qu'on ne sait pas gérer les vaccins
pourquoi est ce que je dis ça parce que
les vaccins c'est un élément d'espoir
les vaccins c'est une sorte de
protection par rapport à la menace de la
pandémie qui ne s'éloigne pas comme on
le pensait les vaccins c'est par
ailleurs le sentiment que les vaccins
sont de plus en plus abstrait c'est à
dire que tu emmanuel macron nous disent
qu'on est des procureurs il aurait mieux
fait parler par exemple aux jeunes sur
qu'est ce qui se passe en termes
d'éléments d'espoir et d'éléments de à
prendre en compte en terme d'
incertitude donc je crois qu'il faut
retrouver un langage très concret il
faut arrêter de qualifier les gens en
disant qu'ils sont des procureurs ce qui
est un terme que personne ne comprend
très bien
personne ne sait très bien qu est ce que
c'est qu'un procureur c'est ce n'est
effectivement comme vous venez de le
dire que ça peut renvoyer au droit au
pénal au procès et à l'éloignement entre
le pouvoir et ceux qui n'ont pas le
pouvoir
et puis je pense que quand on est devant
des jeunes on pratique l'empathie on
leur dit mais comment est-ce que se
passe votre vie quotidienne
on pose des questions au lieu d'asséner
des vérités ou l'autre vincent vous avez
commencé à y répondre tout à l'heure en
citant raymond aron
mais nicole nous dit forcément que ça ne
lui plaît pas il ne supporte pas la
critique emmanuel macron dit on ne fait
pas on ne fait pas face à la crise en
étant une critique vraiment c'est la
critique ne pas menacer là où ses
parades moyens et et étrangers peut-être
il faut aussi prendre des éléments
extrêmement prosaïque eu de la vie
peut-être il ya la fatigue c'est des
journées un travail énorme et c'est je
ne crois pas que c'était dans le texte
et la suite de son propos et un mea
culpa il dit qui ne fait pas d'erreur
aidé à gravir on avance en faisant des
erreurs donc il reconnaît qu'ils en ont
fait donc si vous voulez la voir un
droit à la fois là et il a raison et
personne ne lui en voudra
mais pourquoi donne t il l'impression de
mettre en accusation les français puis
les électeurs et comme quelque chose
d'une immense maladresse aux lucides la
dc s'était attaqué à l'opposition il est
de la politique mais là il ya quelque
chose quand même détonnant de dire à
ceux qui l'ont élu et à qui il a demandé
de le réélire une seconde fois de leur
dire qu'il se comporte pas de de la
bonne façon dont qu'il voulait en fait
axe dire qu'on accepte la critique et il
fait une phrase qui aura l'effet inverse
de ceux de ce qu'ils voulaient dire
alors c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu depuis
depuis depuis qu'il est élu il a il a
l'habitude de ce genre de formules le
problème c'est que cette habitude a
souvent le même la même comment dire
elle est souvent composée de la même
façon c'est-à-dire lui dit comme à
sachant que les autres ceux qui les
français n'ont pas très bien compris ne
sont pas au niveau ne sont du fait de
leur caractère réfractaires ne sont pas
adaptés à la situation qui pourrait
pourtant lui aborde de façon que la
voyante donc ça ça va il avait médité
parvenu à faire disparaître cette image
va immédiatement restaurer ce que je
pense c'est que si emmanuel macron avait
dit au fond ce qui aujourd'hui je sais
pas si c'est les éliminant tout cas le
milieu par exemple je prends cet exemple
de sa proposition de référendum sur
l'écologie il ya eu un concert de
critiques
il ya eu une espèce de l'est je ris tout
le monde s'y est mis en disant mais non
c'est pas possible c'est une manoeuvre
moi je trouve qu emmanuel macron a eu
très souvent depuis le début de son
quinquennat
vraiment une capacité à prendre des
initiatives à faire des choses qui
étaient inédites certaine manière dont
on pourrait rapprocher sa de nicolas
sarkozy et pour moi ce n'est pas un
compliment mais en tout cas il a cette
capacité de mouvement et en ce sens je
trouve qu'il a raison d'être dans le
mouvement et le mea culpa qui fait
ensuite sur les erreurs c'est aussi très
intéressant à ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
présents de la république qui ont fait
ce genre de mea culpa
non mais il a aussi cette capacité par
goût du bon mot par goût du théâtre
quelque part à faire qu'on n'entend pas
les choses qui pourraient être vues
positionnement par rapport à lui comme
si le en même temps justement de son
côté allé trop loin et qui restait
d'ailleurs parce qu il ya une vraie
susceptibilités aujourd'hui on est à
fleur de peau c'est à dire que la vie
est difficile
voilà et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
rapport à ça il faut qu'il fasse
attention que tout ce qui fait ne soient
pas portés à son discrédit alors même
qui fait des choses inédites et
intéressante enfin pour terminer le rôle
de
la chef c'est de faire en sorte de ne
pas faire d'erreur on va prendre tout le
monde en fait et ensuite de vérifier que
ceux qui travaillent avec lui n'en font
pas et d'empêcher qu'il y en ait le plus
possible or là sur quoi les français ont
reporté leur défiance s'est pas sur les
décisions de restriction de liberté qui
sont pénibles mais qui qui qui qui
peuvent être entendus compte tenu de la
situation c'est sur la logistique des
vaccins et sur des éléments pratiques où
justement là la force publique doit
pouvoir montrer sa capacité à faire un
certain nombre de choses et ils ont
montré qu'ils n'avaient perdu 4 dans
cette zone ils ont eu à forcer de
défiance et de propos de procureur ils
ont dû accélérer ils ont dû faire mieux
faire plus vite bon là on manque de
doses donc ça va ça va malheureusement
s'arrêter mais ça risque malheureusement
de sa de s'arrêter pour pour ou d'aller
moins vite pendant jusqu'à ce qu'on
reçoit de nouvelles doses mais donc
c'est là c'est une critique pratique
lui-même à exprimer donc il ya quelque
chose de louper dans l'absolu je sais
pas ce que c'est je ne sais pas comment
fumer mais c'est une maladresse mais
prône le registre sémantique c'est là
qu'il faut qu'il fasse attention et
vacances parce que je parlais dans gala
mériel et son langage très concret c'est
qu'il faut dire des choses très
concrètes très enracinée et là les
procureurs cette espèce d'image surgi de
nulle part déjà qui nous arrive dessus
personne ne sait ce que ça veut dire
personne ne se sent vraiment concerné et
tout le monde a l'impression de
stigmatiser attention et allons dans le
concret est à présent de la république
de la logistique
après tout ça serait une nouvelle une
nouveauté une réforme si l'état
sollicité davantage le peuple par
législatives intermédiaires par
référendum etc
je pense nous dit cet internaute que le
peuple serait moins critique est ce que
c'est votre avis en tout cas alors il ya
un élément qui était dans l'air qui a
l'air de s'estomper qui est celui de la
proportionnelle
qui était un des natures été un des
éléments à mon avis de début de
réconciliation entre les catégories
populaires et les représentants
politiques et là c'était très risqué de
la part d' emmanuel macron lui aurait
dit on fait pas ça pendant le coc vie il
aurait subi des critiques disant il fait
de la politique politicienne ni
manoeuvre il a fait rentrer le front
national en masse à l'assemblée etc il
n'empêche quand vous entendez les
arguments avancés par où jean louis
bourlanges dans le figaro lundi
ils sont très très convaincant c'est à
dire que la crise politique pour aux
causes passe pas unique mais une déco
c'est la crise de la représentation et
la proportionnelle permettrait aurait
permis de pallier un peu à cette crise
de la représentation
apparemment on sait pas les élections
qu'on est entrain de temps moi je pense
que ce qui est je suis d'accord avec
l'idée qu'il faut retrouver d'autres
liens mais le sujet c'est de faire
interagir davantage pas seulement
emmanuel macron et les français mais
l'ensemble de ceux qui incarnent les
institutions par exemple sur la
convention citoyenne le cafouillage
c'est que le parlement et la convention
citoyenne n'ont jamais sur l'écologie
sur le climat n'ont jamais interagit en
amont du coup ça donne un sentiment que
personne n'a de place ni les citoyens ni
les députés néo emmanuel macron et du
coup le référendum c'est quand même eux
et moi et moi je trouve ça dangereux
dans l'ambiance actuelle
mais comment est ce qu'on fait pour
retrouver le lien entre la société et
ceux qui incarnent eux l'état sans que
ce soit toujours l'interpellation la
négation ont peut-être les procureurs
mais là dessus mais elle m'a qu'on a une
responsabilité à organiser cette
interaction société état est d'autant
plus que ça relève à la fois du sujet de
la pandémie des inégalités l'écologie il
y a de quoi faire un nouveau contrat
social
donc je suis d'accord avec cet
internaute mais pas seulement avec le
référendum c'est avec la question tous
les cas quand vous posez sur twitter
droite en danger le pseudo d'une matière
d'auto ou d'une internaute vous dit les
français ne sont pas critiques ils sont
réalistes
en tout cas on a posé la question sur
twitter pensez vous comme emmanuel
macron que les français forment une
nation de procureurs et vos réponses
sont partagés puisque
vous répondez non mais à 59% alors le
nom a un peu augmenté depuis depuis une
demi-heure environ puisque c'était avant
autour de 57 % donc mais ça reste c'est
assez partagés donc peut-être qu'il y
aura un écho dans ce que dans ce que
emmanuel macron a dit non les autres
diront c'est le procureur c'est eux et
pas moi oui voilà ça va pas ça dit il ya
une critique on va dire légitimiste qui
consiste à dire on est en guerre et donc
tout ce que fait le pouvoir en place et
est valable est donc bon bah c'est
normal que ça c'est ça s'exprime il
n'empêche que peut-être qu'il y aura des
gens autour d'emmanuel mettront pour
dire que finalement c'était judicieux
puisque les sondages ne sais pas si
catastrophique qui me semble que s'ils
s'étaient abstenus ce serait meilleur
pour lui en tous les cas effectivement
la question composé n'était pas à 100
c'est une autre question si une armée y
aura des surtout être écriront visiteurs
oui on imagine en tout cas on est comme
on prend et alban l'autre question qu'on
pose sur twitter c'est si xavier gorce
et victime du politiquement correct
alors je vous rappelle la sphère dans
l'édition datée du 19 janvier de la
newsletter matinale
le brief du monde du quotidien le
créateur des indéchiffrables a publié un
dessin relatif au mouvement actuel sur
les questions d'inceste créé par la
sphère olivier duhamel et qui a suscité
des saints qui a suscité une vive
polémique dans les réseaux sociaux on y
voyait un petit pingouin demandant un
pingouin plus âgés si j'ai été abusé je
cite par le demi frère adoptif de la
campagne de mon père transgenres devenu
ma mère est ce un inceste
alors on va l'entendre xavier gorce de
dit que ce dessin été mal compris il est
pourtant clair selon lui c'est une
ironie sur les propos de cannes un
finkielkraut avait tenus sur lci qui
s'interrogeait sur le fait de savoir ce
qui était un as eh bien c est comme si
cela pouvait amoindrir la faute morale
donc on précise que le caricaturiste a
voulu se moquer de ceux qui relativisent
et la pédophilie
elle insiste l'inceste pardon pour le
reste voici son plaidoyer
c'est pas la première fois que le que
j'ai à une admonestation comme ça sur un
décembre disant qu'il n'aurait pas dû
être publié
moi je juge que c'est cet argument est
mauvais je pense que mon dessin je suis
pas là pour défendre sa qualité pour
dire s'il est comment dire juste je
crois qu'il mais je crois qu'il est
inattaquable sur ce que je dis quand on
soupèse des mots quand le lit avec son
intelligence et avec son émotivité
je crois que ce dessin tient
parfaitement la route lucile est ce que
vous êtes d'accord et xavier gorce est
ce que ça nous a choqués le dessin n'a
pas choqué mais je comprends très bien
qu'il choque et et je crois que quand il
dit il faut lire avec l'intelligence et
pas avec l'émotivité sur des sujets
comme celui là l'intelligence et
l'émotivité se mêlent profondément je
voyais par exemple qu'un député la
république en marche renaud qu est l
avait dit j'ai été abusée à 11 ans si je
m'attendais à cette révélation de la
part d'un député d'un homme public je
pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur les
souffrances et traumatismes et je pense
que la difficulté qu'on a par rapport à
xavier gorce
c'est au fond que tout le monde se met à
penser aussi à ce qui s'est passé autour
des caricatures et de charlie hebdo et
pense aussi à ce que à ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis avec c'était avec
le herald qui a décidé de publier ou le
new york times aussi ce matin de new
york times qui a décidé de ne plus
publier de caricatures donc on est dans
une situation où quelque part la sphère
entre guillemets xavier gorce ne peut
pas être lui seulement par rapport à
ceux ce dessin mais crée une espèce de
débat de principe est qu'il faut
regarder très concrètement
moi je me suis aussi rappelé en pensant
à ça je raconte ma vie mais à ce qui
s'était passé quand j'étais en algérie
dans la décennie 90 où la plupart des
caricaturistes de la presse algérienne
ont été contraints à l'exil
parce qu'ils critiquaient le pouvoir
algérien et qu'il recevait des menaces
ali dilem par exemple parce qu'il m
l'excellent que de merveilleux
caricaturiste dans ce pays
ce qu'on n'aurait pas forcément imaginé
donc je j'ai dit j'ai du mal à me faire
une idée tranchée mais je comprends très
bien qu'on ait pu être choqués par ce
dessin en revanche je trouve que le
directeur du monde aurait dû en parler
avec xavier gorce parce que ce que j'ai
compris c'est que
le démenti ou le commentaire l'excusent
avaient été faites sans en parler à
xavier gorce
là je trouve qu'il ya un vrai sujet par
respect qui lui est dû mais je comprends
la position du monde
vincent est ce que vous êtes vous
partage le point de vue de lucile ou est
ce que vous partagez sur une mathieu
slama qui voit dans la dénonciation et
le retrait donc du dessin le symptôme
d'une régression démocratique d'une
culture je cite d'une culture puritaine
et liberticide qui vient des états unis
qui se pose toute l'histoire à la
culture française et qui remet en
question de manière radicale notre
conception de la liberté d'expression je
pense qu'il faut pas pour répondre il
faut pas tout confondre parce que comme
dit lucile maintenant avec ces histoires
parce qu'il y en a une toutes les
semaines on a tendance à invoquer un
certain nombre de mots qui ne sont pas
forcément adaptées alors le premier
c'est le mot censure là un journal a la
possibilité et la direction du monde la
possibilité de dire en amont à lui aviez
gorce écoute je sais pas si ce dessin
est très emballant pourquoi pourquoi le
public tu es ce que tu en ferait pas nos
tripes et après ça se passe où ça se
passe pas à chaque arme en sait des
conversations qui peuvent exister enfin
on rappelle d'ailleurs que chaque jour
chaque média à un directeur de
publication et donc il ya une
responsabilité aussi dans les
publications et là il n'y avait pas de
pros mais bon voilà c'est des
conversations qu'on peut savoir cause la
légitimité voilà qui file et qui existe
et c'est des choses qu'on appelle des
choix éditoriaux mon maintenant ce
dessin il a été publié
donc à partir du moment où il a été
publié ça engage quand même le titre
qu'il a publiés et le fait de le des
pubs liés ou en tout cas de le désavouer
tout désavoué inanimé de le désavouer
publiquement
c'est quand même que c'est une attitude
qui apparaît
convaincre moi je ne partage pas et que
je déplore parce que je trouve qu'elle
ne se qu'ils désavouent n'y gagne pas
grand chose et celui qui est désavoué
assumer et vexée publiquement donc il ya
un moment on a dessus mais il ya une
décision qui a été prise ou non prise
parce qu'avec le internet il ya des
trucs qui part dans tous les sens on
l'assumé c'est comme ça d'autant que on
arrive à la deuxième au deuxième point
c'est que le problème c'est pas charlie
par scharner puisque pareil on fait des
confusions être charlie c'est quoi c'est
faire en sorte et vouloir de toute sa
force que charlie hebdo puisse exister
puisse exister sereinement et dans la
paix mais c'est pas que tous les
journaux deviennent charlie hebdo c'est
pas la même chose et que les caricatures
de charlie se retrouve partout s'est
passé pas alors nous par exemple on les
avait publiés dans le figaro pour
montrer notre soutien mais chaque
journal à sa vision propre sur son
identité et donc développe donc
peut-être que le monde aurait trouvé que
des cinq catégories ça n'allait pas sûr
plein dit orianne maintenant ils ont ils
ont désavoué ce dessin pourquoi et c'est
là où ça on arrive à mon avis au coeur
du problème
alors il faudrait dans la rédaction du
monde savoir si ça venait de la
rédaction ou de twitter mais il ya en
tout cas des groupes de pression
extrêmement actif je ne sais pas s'ils
sont représentatifs mais qui sont très
actifs et qui cible un certain nombre de
personnes
quand ces personnes sont sur dans la
sphère publique soit par des extraits
vidéo soit par des dessins en disant
vous m'avez en france et vous m'avez
blessé
comment pouvez vous laisser faire ça et
à partir de là est ce que la décision du
directeur de la directrice de la
rédaction est une décision serait où
elle est faite sous cette pression et
est ce que cette pression est
l'expression d'une opinion publique
importante et structuré ou est-ce que
c'est l'expression de d'activistes
politiques ou idéologiques et celle là
ou communautaires et c'est là où à mon
avis il faut prendre le temps avant de
prendre des décisions singers parler de
finkielkraut mais quand lci décidant en
un quart d'heure de lui supprimer son sa
chronique hebdomadaire
c'est pareil c'est sous cette pression
là et donc c'est une décision qui n'est
pas une décision fondée sur j'observe ce
qu'a dit la personne qui est mise en
cause
ce que ce que dit la critique ce que
pensent les lecteurs ce que pense la
rédaction cela des conversations qu'on
peut avoir avec la personne qui est mise
en cause
et puis à la fin ont décidé on dit bon
bah on fonce là non ça va très très vite
c'est une espèce de compulsion il ya un
moment d'émotion il ya une décision qui
est unilatéral et c'est à mon avis ça
qui choque
si après il y avait eu une conversation
entre la directrice du monde et xavier
gorce pour direct coût de ces a sans
doute été cinq finales en jane est ce
qu'on a la même ligne bon bah ça ça
arrive dans tout
dans tous les journaux dans tous les
types de médias là il ya une brutalité
une rapidité qui qui qui est une
déclaration de xavier gorce qui fait la
preuve de ce de ce tribunal quotidien
qui est devenu twitter et que sont
devenus twitter et facebook et qui fait
que chaque jour quelqu'un peut être
ciblés avec des conséquences concrètes
sur sa vie professionnelle je repars
être car une foreuse puisqu'il a écrit
un livre sur justement la tyrannie de
france elle a fait un tweet à propos de
don de de cette affaire on lui met et on
va on va lire elle dit notamment cette
l'époque ces fausses s'offusque de tout
du crime comme de son commentaire est-ce
que là il n'ya pas aussi un problème et
elle dit si on continue à faire comme ça
on nivelle ratou je pense que il faut
arrêter les généralités et de dire que
les excuses de jérôme fenoglio où les
demandes de caroline monnot
niveler tout et que la censure va régner
en france moi je trouve qu'il faut
relativiser
je comprends que xavier gorce soient
furieux parce qu'il ya eu un problème de
manière à son égard qui était très
grossière et notamment vous avez tout à
fait raison de lierre vincent je pense
que quand on fait un journal parfois on
est pris par le temps et qu'on évalue
mal a priori l'émotion qui peut être
suicidé
moi je pense pas là dessus je serais pas
d'accord avec vous je pense pas qu'il ya
des groupes de pression sur la question
de l'inceste je pense qu'il ya une
émotion énorme qui a été déclenchée je
pense que pas sur la question de
l'inceste mais sur la question des
questions de transgenre peut-être qu'à
des groupes de pression sur la question
du sens jean et a sûrement effectivement
il ya des associations qui défendent
très fortement les transgenres mais je
crois que c'est quand même un vrai sujet
l'inceste et qu'on a devant nous un
débat qui s'exercent les gradins et puis
alors peut-être que vous dites il faut
pas tout mélanger par rapport à charlie
peut-être qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
mais évidemment avec cette affaire on
repense aux caricatures et on ne va pas
tout mélanger mais on peut penser et
j'ose le dire sur le plateau du figaro
live que du coup la façon dont certains
musulmans qui ne sont pas des
terroristes on peut ressentir les
caricatures de charlie hebdo était aussi
très émotionnel d'ailleurs que au fond
ce ce qui se passe avec xavier gorce
nous éclaire aussi sur le fait que nous
n'avons pas tous la même sensibilité la
même manière de percevoir les choses et
que les principes de liberté se heurte
aussi parfois aux émotions
voyez moi voilà ce que j'entends les
gardes ou c'est la même définition vous
avez raison dans mon constat mais on
avait tous la même définition de la
liberté
parce que la liberté tel que que nous
l'avions parce qu'elle est en train de
s'atténuer ou que nous la vivons encore
de façon erratique
c'est pour moi trésor dont nous avons
hérité mais c'est la liberté d'être
choqué la liberté de supporter des
choses qu'on n'a pas envie d'en temps
lâché de la liberté parfois d'être
blessé ou d'être vexé dans ce qu'on est
et parfois même dans dans dans la
catégorie sociale qu'on représente dans
dans le les idées que l'on a dans la
peut-être dans la religion que l'on
pratique dans tous les éléments de
l'existence il ya la possibilité
d'entendre des choses qui sont
désagréables mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'elles ne doivent pas être dit non
mais moi j'ai pas trouvé le dessin de
xavier gorce drôle
non et je c'est un dessinateur que je ce
qui me passionne pas enfin mais cela ne
veut pas dire que je je vais madinier du
fait que par exemple il a fait des
dessins sur les gilet jaune très dur
très agressif
moi je peux gilet jaune mais si un gilet
jaune disait il faut plus de xavier
gorce parce qu'il s'est attaqué à nous
non mais là ça fait partie de la vie bon
là il y en a eu il n'y a pas eu l'idée
qu'ils auraient plus de dessins de
xavier c'est à dire qu'il a choisi
volontairement de démissionner mais ce
qui est très important par rapport à ce
que vous dites sur la liberté pour qui
tu sais que cette question de la liberté
par rapport à l'inceste
elle est posée évidemment parce qu'au
fond ce que nous a dit le livre de
camille kouchner s'était que la liberté
d'olivier duhamel et plus généralement
du monde des adultes dans son allure non
mais xavier gorce clos tous les caddies
que justement les jeunes ou tel jour est
juste terminer ma relation à entretenir
qu'on défend là c'est sur ce plateau
mais que cette question de la liberté si
aujourd'hui elle met mal à l'aise c'est
parce que quelque part on a l'impression
que les institutions et on revient à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure ne sont pas
suffisamment solides pour faire en sorte
que les libertés collectives soit
défendu de manière telle que certains
n'en souffrent pas on n'est pas les
sentiments d'en souffrir c'est le cas
pour les faibles les jeunes les gens qui
ont subi des choses ça peut être aussi
le ressenti des gilets jaunes dans
certains dans certains cas et donc cette
question la liberté il faut l'articuler
à tout prix avec le fait que les
institutions qui font que la loi est
respectée soit des institutions solides
je crois que c'est ça le débat au fond
derrière ça c'est des institutions mais
c'est aussi des astuces et des
institutions qui sont pas publiques
c'est à dire que lassé des pratiques et
notamment dans des structures privées et
notamment celle des réseaux sociaux où
l'on ne doit pas s'habituer à ce que par
mimétisme numérique y ait chaque jour
une personne qui fasse le on appelle ça
un dérapage le la provocation et qu'ils
soient ciblées avec à chaque fois de
conséquence deux exigences de cette
meute qui est le procès il faut l'amener
devant les juges ou la disqualification
professionnel pourquoi vous employez
cette personne et donc ça il me semble
que c'est pas une pratique démocratique
que l'on dise je suis scandalisée du
propos de xavier du dessin de xavier
gorce en écrivant au monde
pourquoi vous publiez ça ça fait partie
de la vie des journaux bien sûr mais que
l'on n'actionne par un certain nombre de
messages et j'en ai vu beaucoup disent
en être le monde pourquoi vous employer
quelqu'un comme ça ça veut dire qu'on
demande l'interdiction professionnelle
et ça ça se développe énormément et ça
me paraît extraordinairement bas mais
surtout moi je ne fais pas partie d'un
journal et je ne participe à votre
processus de fabrication du journal
et c'est au fond c'est ça qui est assez
passionnant c'est qu'il me semble que
les moments et les lieux de discussion
collective où les choses peuvent se
confronter sont peut-être trop rare
c'est à dire qu'avec la le temps qui
s'accélère les pressions comme vous le
dites ou la peur dépression ou la peur
de déplaire à quel moment est ce que au
sein de la rédaction il ya eu une
analyse ou une discussion contradictoire
même de controverse par rapport à ce
dessin c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser et c'est la question posée très
justement par xavier gorce
moi je le défends pas mordicus vous
l'avez senti mais je trouve que la façon
dont il dit au fond le truc m'est tombé
sur la tête et j'ai appris par la bande
ce qui était arrivé à mon dessin ça je
trouve ça scandaleux la ja ce mot cette
question du fonctionnement collectif
mais on pourrait peut-être tirer comme
enseignement à la fois de l'éviction de
finkielkraut de lci est et de l'avenue
des pères de xavier gorce le fait que
les décisions de d'éviction ou de
désavouer le dessinateur
encore une fois je ne veux pas le faire
elle son monde celui décide mais laisser
le temps
c'est à dire que comme vous le dites la
formation continue ne laisse pas le
temps c'est une compulsion et la
décision qui est une décision grave à
lourdes conséquences
avec une portée symbolique énorme elle
doit parfois y en a ça existe mais il
faut prendre le temps et en général
quand on prend le temps ça s'apaise
parce que les polémiques naissent et
meurent en 24 heures sur ces réseaux là
et c'est quand même eux qui les
entretiennent après nous aussi dans le
journal il ya quelque chose qui a déplu
aux lecteurs on est vraiment en
profondeur on sait ça remonte ses romans
de ça remonte mais il ya un certain
nombre de polémiques qui naissent sur
une demi-journée puis qui disparaissent
comme elles sont elles sont apparues
donc il faut les prendre en compte faut
s'interroger est ce qu'on a bien fait ce
qu'on n'a pas bien fait ce qu'il disait
digitimes est-ce que c'est pas légitime
mais il faut le faire avec des éléments
qui permettent la sérénité et le temps
fait partie de ces éléments je donne la
parole justement ou lecteur enfin tous
les cas aux internautes et j'espère vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à lire et
surtout à vous abonner au figaro il ya
plein de tarifs donc c'est très
intéressant n'hésitez pas le général
escape
c'est un pseudo à ses yeux dessus sur
youtube estime que gorges fait les frais
de la censure au nom de la bien pensante
sabine nous dit crainte l'humour soit un
droit qu'on nous retire la place de
l'humour a bien reculé nous dit cet
autre internaute chardons bleus il y
voit un peu la caricature de la société
actuelle qui mélange un peu tout sous
prétexte de modernité
notre internaute de marie nous dit je
trouve qu'il ya des limites sur les
caricatures
ce n'est qu'un dessin en revanche estime
christophe de l'humour
heureusement qu'on ne rit pas de tous
tous des mêmes choses on ne va pas aussi
établir un humour d'état pour vous poser
la question le sur twitter est ce que
selon vous xavier gorce et victime du
politiquement correct
et pour vous enfin ceux qui ont répondu
vous êtes une large majorité à répondre
oui on pourra continuer à débattre de
tout ça des caricatures également merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouver guillaume roquette même
heure même endroit avec le retour de
guillaume bernard et de fergane asia a
très vite sur fear alive
[Musique]